latest in another high profile shooting
in america it happened last night in a
church near birmingham alabama police
say a gunman killed two people and
wounded a third barely a month after
another deadly shooting in a church in
california mark straussman has the story
we have multiple people that have been
shot vestavia hills police raced to
saint stephen's episcopal church
thursday evening the call was about an
active shooter they say the gunman acted
alone entering a small church meeting
and opening fire before being taken into
custody shooter has been held down at
this time but the scene is not secure
two people were killed a third injured
investigators did not share a motive for
the attack according to the church's
website a potluck dinner was scheduled
for around the time of the shooting
deeply moved by the radical support of
love from many
people reaching out from all over the
country over the past month deadly mass
shootings at a buffalo supermarket and a
texas elementary school have renewed
demands for gun reform according to a
recent fbi report the number of active
shooter incidents has skyrocketed last
year jumping more than 50 percent from
the previous year and more than 96
percent from 2017
leaving communities like vestavia hills
heartbroken we need everybody out there
whatever your faith or your belief
system is to pray to think to meditate
to send love to this community because
they're going to need all of it for cbs
mornings i'm mark straussman